you
I hope you all have a lot of water lying
around cuz I think between my talk and
potentially Ryan's we're gonna have a
lot of node mentioned so anyway hello
this is merge conflict conflict
resolution and management for developers
as they said I'm Tracy Hines
I'm platform manager and international
operations at Samsung next by day by all
other hours I'm working on node in the
community and a cat herder of
conferences and a nonprofit gather
script by most other hours you can find
me on github and Twitter and the far
corners of the internet as hack you go
lucky and I just want to say thanks for
being here and listening to me for a few
minutes about some of this stuff a
disclaimer I am NOT a licensed
psychotherapist my undergraduate
education was a Bachelor of Science
degree in psychology and sociology but
what that mostly means is that I spent
four years trying to diagnose myself
with some disorder I'm trained in crisis
counseling as well as peer mediation
conflict management I've also had
experience in practicing that but this
talk is not a substitution for going and
getting trained yourself and being
supervised by licensed experts to teach
you how to execute on some of these
lessons but we're going to talk about
all of that today in the tongue as the
education community manager of node and
now on the moderation team I'm leading
the conflict management training program
for node leadership and collaborators
and those are the folks who keep the
project ticking for the millions of
users we're gonna walk through applying
that education to open source developers
distributed across the globe and report
in on removing barriers to stability
through improving developer productivity
with healthy communication and
collaboration as peer conflict
management so back when programmers were
running tests and prepping for the y2k
bug and gdpr was a millennial lifetime
away my middle school leaders found
themselves at an impasse with a pretty
impossible challenge on their hands tons
of fights and lots of physical violence
was going on I went to public school and
students were pouring into the guy
councilor with what seemed to the adults
to be really small arguments and mostly
fueled by puberty long dismissing those
problems they finally agreed to bring in
an experiment and that was a peer
mediation program every student in the
school was required to take the training
a room a space for the peer mediation
was dedicated a teacher was only in
there to sit and watch and stay quiet
the peers we were required to visit and
volunteer at the peer mediation
classroom once a week as if it were
study hall so the guidance counselors
and teachers were no longer breaking up
the fights they were teaching the
teenagers untrusting of outsiders to
solve their problems to learn the
complexity of conflict how to
communicate what they are feeling why
they are feeling it and to be able to
calmly dialogue about their
disagreements and the occurrences of
fighting dropped dramatically
so someone you relate to going through
the same history quizzes and algebra two
exams they don't look or act like you
but they have to make it to the other
side just like you something hiding
underneath the surface of this story is
that we don't wake up having these tools
to facilitate conflict naturally it has
to be cultivated as kids or even as
adults this is a gift given to me by my
secondary education and I thought that
the training may translate to are
distributed much more online world if
done with care so we are programmers but
we're also human and I get very very
fired up in debates it feels good even
if only temporary to think that you're
right when you've taken it too far
though built up this idea of another
person on the other side of the screen
who's doing something so intentionally
malicious you're talking past each other
there's no understanding motivations the
words on your screen are just the
surface layer of what's going on so what
is conflict conflict gets a really bad
rap but that's a bit unfair it isn't
inherently bad modern theories consider
conflict a natural and inevitable
outcome of
human interaction conflict situations
also often lead to the generation of new
ideas and positive change so that's a
lot to unpack let's talk some approaches
that we can use as instruments to put in
our toolboxes to communicate a little
more kindly in our everyday work so the
work we've done thus far with the node
moderation team has through haunting
governance and taking a very deep look
at what we need to change to modify
behavior incidentally mirrored when a
Nobel prize-winning economist Elinor
Ostrom wrote of governance of the
Commons and evidence-based social design
limit Effects of bad behavior and that's
through moderation systems making an
appropriate post less prominent keeping
consistent moderation policies including
community members in the moderation
offering reversion tools and introducing
filters limit bad behavior itself you
can do that through activity quotas
temporary or permanent bans and
consistent criteria for the bans
outlined with process encourage
voluntary compliance by ensuring that
people learn the norms showing examples
of appropriate or inappropriate behavior
but not too often and dwelling on it
displaying statistics on the normative
behavior and reminding people about the
norms at the point of action so with the
advent of social coding through github
online communities have broken down
physical location differences in
communication barriers creating a new
challenge with folks who are not
employed by the same company but
collaborating on a common goal the speed
at which we pass both positive and
negative information it'll you know it's
a breakneck pace so even if we were to
be at the same company a well-meaning
manager a very well staffed HR firm or
internal team they would have a hard
time keeping up so with volunteer
contributing as is much the way of many
open source projects attention and time
are a very limited resource low quality
contributions such as commenting without
seeking out some context prior creates a
social dilemma
these contributions drown out other
contributions with time and emotional
labor and often exhaust the available
attention so conflict researchers have
studied this and you know the effects on
coasts or software development at least
is easier to track so dr. Steve Sawyer
surveyed 40 packaged software
development teams and concluded that how
people work together and mitigate
conflict is more important than the
individual skills and ability of the
team's members in predicting their
software developer performance so yeah
what do you think node project activity
looks like when we've ended up in big
fights on Twitter or on long essays of
debates going back and forth on github
long derail the issue at hand PRS and
pushes dropped to a crawl when comments
shoot up so we're makers and there's no
doubt we love to fix things and we're
paid to problem-solve but we can't fix
them all and we can certainly not do all
of this good work alone but we try
through trial and error in iterating
over governance moderation policies and
codes of conducts and in values
consensus so as moderators at open
source we lay the groundwork for
participants to understand one another's
perspectives for a conflict management
system to work we had to establish that
power grounding first we don't have to
argue or sorry we don't have to agree to
get along but a common understanding and
a value system context is important to
effective interaction so last year the
first thing that we did was meet as the
top-level project committees and we ran
a core value session at collaboration
summit even with its global impact node
had relied on a very implicit
understanding of community members
expectations core values serve as the
boundaries within which an organization
organization will operate in pursuit of
its vision moving forward we needed to
codify expectations on so that we could
work effectively together and empower
members to act in the best interest of a
very global node it was also vital that
we address leadership guidelines in the
project to model good behavior practices
so we created the member expectations
file it's important that members of our
leadership group that was the TSC
community committee also the members of
the board act in a way that not only
complies with the code of dhunda but
that models the vision mission and
operating principles of the node project
that we're seeking cultural acceptance
so cultural elements underlying
conflicts are really important
consideration we need to bear in mind
adding an extra edge and degree of
sensitivity to the difficult tasks of
mediation and peace building this
includes perception checking how our own
perception is affecting the conflict
we're a part of and what influences our
mental programming has on how we are
perceiving creative ways of handling
conflicts often emerge from the adoption
of a flexible pragmatic outlook in short
one size does not fit all a nuanced
approach to conflict through listening
first gaining context from parties
proceeding with care in the spaces with
which the parties feel comfortable often
allow for early resolve instead of
continued management the tooling so I'd
be remiss to not dive in a bit into the
tooling constraints that we as
open-source moderators of conflict have
where do your communities live for node
we live on github we live on Twitter we
in fact for some time had a magnitude
more tweets about than the next most
active programming language Java I'm not
kidding or being a hyperbolic node has
grown up with github we've felt the pain
of what it means to limit permissions of
contributors for Security's sake and
then moderators don't have access to act
swiftly to edit or ban bad actors we've
also celebrated the awesome work they've
done in recent years with incredible
features giving the power to maintain
errs to better fine tune permission
reduce noise and ensure productive
conversations through issue locking and
user blocking
being able to quickly apply Community
Guidelines to a repo and then there's
scope we had to take a step back and
look at what space is our ecosystem
interacts in but also what we have
control over we can work to improve the
environment and github because we
control that space we have the
permissions and the administrative tools
to do that
but what about Twitter or reddit or
hacker news we chose a strategy of
tackling the scope we could commit to
ensuring safety and healthy dialogue in
for moderation so as github select slack
and IRC groups and events that can be
tough when many of us have found
subcommittees in these spaces that are
really helpful but we spent a lot of
time trying to help in these phases and
we've ended up with over exposed and
attacked community members so the who
the node moderation team we have an
elevated responsibility to observe
patterns audit processes and draft new
governance to improve our workspaces of
the node project the top-level
committees the TSC which is the
technical steering committee and the
community committee are voting members
who jointly select or object to any
person on the moderation team and the
process verifies the shared trust
project computer contributors have with
those who are ending up selected so
let's be clear though as I move through
these examples and as I've said already
perspective is vital to being effective
in these challenges and we still lack in
diversity on the moderation team I think
that's echoed from much of the node
project which also means that we have
gaps in time zone coverage we will never
be effect as effective as a group when
the makeup of our team doesn't mirror
the makeup of the developer community we
would like to see a note so this is an
uphill battle worth fighting as
moderators we respect that maintaining
trust is key to being effective in
conflict management we get to be the
bridge builders dispel skepticism and
fear in place of an expectation of
acting in good faith we remove conflict
barriers as facilitators of
conversations so now that we've got the
who what and why let's
so anyone that wants to request
moderation can do so they do not have to
be a member of our organization
requesting moderation of a post can be
accomplished in one of four ways the
first is to email to report at no jst
work the second is a private email it's
one of our moderation team members which
are listed in our readme with their
email and their full contact information
you can also file an issue in the same
or sorry a new post in the same thread
as the post with the moderation request
we can also request moderation via a new
issue in nodejs moderation repo so
collaborators can moderate non
collaborator collaborator posts at any
time without submitting a request we're
getting a request by someone else so
this is because while we have a
moderation team anyone with a
collaborator status is helping
contribute to the values expressed
through repeated interactions with
participants the moderation team helps
set policy and modeling but all
collaborators can and will moderate or
can and moderate by default and we're
gonna talk a little later about how
we're working to be intentional and
better prepare all of those
collaborators for this so when a request
is sent by email to report at no js' org
or directly to a moderation team member
a new issue detailing that request has
to be logged in nodejs
/ moderation the identity of the
individuals submitting the request is
emitted from the issue unless permission
has been included this brings us back to
scoping the space for handling conflict
- the space appropriate for it
when you're having a conflict with a
co-worker does your manager or HR sit
you down in an open office and try and
talk to you about it no they generally
take you into a more private setting
where you can feel comfortable to talk
candidly but also gain perspective
without feeling judged or feeling judged
but that's also easier to swallow in
private the moderation repo is a private
repo but everyone who is a collaborator
who is an engaged
active participant in the project has
permission to view and interact on these
threads hundreds of folks we do this so
folks are able to offer help insight and
context by reducing the scope of
exposure when we're dealing with these
issues filed
we're also avoiding the drive-bys scope
and audience are vital to managing what
is within your control of change and
what require is tackling from multiple
dependencies or groups to affect change
on the scale that's required so a great
example of this is when momentum builds
off of a reddit post sorry total Quinn
says when a harassing post is made on
reddit if it's reported to us and we
don't have the bandwidth to alert on
everything that's happening and node
trolling on the Internet we will try to
address it we learned the hard way with
this one though we can reach out to
moderators of node reddit as an example
to work with them to rectify but we
can't force them to do anything we can
look to see if the harasser Zoar current
contributors to the project and sanction
them we can make a public statement to
reiterate what we do and do not tolerate
as behavior but what we can do if it is
someone that is not invested in the
project does not generally operate in
our spaces so banning them doesn't
punish them does you know what do we do
with this drive-by harassment we give
them no platform because they are trolls
and they are Kirby's of negative energy
and they will be empowered by us
responding we log these users and we
look for future activity in the project
if they ever engage and try to bring
that toxicity internal thanks to these
experiences as moderation as moderators
we established that requests for
moderation that do not appear to have
been submitted in good faith with the
intent to address a legitimate code of
conduct violation we will ignore it it
turns out some folks will try to
manipulate your moderators to use them
as an attack vector for their harassment
targets
so before moderating a post
collaborators and moderation teams
specifically consider the possible in 10
of the author as I've just said and we
especially try to assume folks are
acting in good faith I mentioned trolls
before but we do not under operating to
the assumption on first look that anyone
is a troll it's possible that the author
is simply made an error or is not yet
familiar with the code of conduct it may
be that cultural differences exist or
that the author is unaware that certain
content is considered inappropriate in
these cases we make no assumption of
mal-intent
and give the author an opportunity to
correct any error that may have been
made but unfamiliarity or
misinterpretations with the code of
conduct does not excuse a post for
moderation moderation team members can
and will remove or block an individual
from the node github org for any removal
or blocking action an issue is
describing the reasons for the action
and identifying the github account being
acted upon must be posted to this
moderation repo for all collaborators to
see with an explanation provided by us
on the moderation team any individual
block from the node github org will be
recommended for exclusion from any node
foundation event as well if the author
of the reporting posting disagrees that
moderation is required such as they
won't edit or retract what they've been
asked to the matter can be escalated to
the moderation team for resolution as
well if the other collaborators request
has not been met
moderation actions should be taken no
moderation actions should be taken until
a decision by the moderation team is
made and I'll explain in a little bit
about why we do that and don't let a
single individual make that call so
trusted folks these are the
collaborators these are folks who are
active and engaging in the project when
a post is authored by another
collaborator for an issue of potential
violation as a moderator I must explain
the justification for moderating the
post identify all changes made to the
post identify the steps previously taken
to resolve the issue
if the moderation action included
blocking as I said before we have to
make sure and file an issue that
demonstrates the justification for the
action
explanations of moderation actions on
collaborator posts must be provided in a
new post within the original thread a
new issue within the the nodejs
moderation repo and any collaborator
habitually violating the Code of Conduct
or this pot moderation policy may be
blocked temporarily or in extreme cases
removed and blocked indefinitely we
don't have a three strikes you're out
because that's not I think sensitive
enough for the levels of interpretation
that we need so we spend time
documenting this activity for
educational purposes and reinforcement
of values we don't want to scare good
humans away from making a mistake
repeated mistakes with no record of
listening or learning is another story
separately there's a lot of folks who
don't hop in threads but they're
observing the modeling logging and
action requirements hold us accountable
to consistency so moderators reduce
their likelihood of being partial this
is especially vital for the folks who
work together day to day and most
important when it comes to leadership in
the project so unknown folks these are
participants who have not yet
established themselves as contributors
or repeated contributors to the project
when a post is offered by another sorry
when a post is offered by one of them
the big difference here is that we have
to dig up any history that we can find
on interactions with these folks because
we don't have a history it is much
harder for us to be able to interpret so
oftentimes it's reaching out to the
individual any way we can to talk to
them privately and then also consulting
with other members of the moderation
team to see if there's something that
can be done such as educating if they
don't respond in a way that feels like
they are learning then we know that what
we need to do but as part of that
because they don't have access to the
collaborators private moderation repo we
have to then try and make a decision and
then make sure to log it in the public
place that this person can see it
there are circumstances where we won't
do that though so again no moderator
makes these decisions alone and no one
bears the burden of that decision alone
historically moderating leads to
retaliation or escalation of
inappropriate behavior by the individual
whose post is being monitored and I
should say it can it doesn't
neccessarily this is true primarily of
individuals whose intent is to harass
disrupt or annoy in an individual member
of the community in these cases it's
best to handle the moderation as quickly
and as quietly as possible without
drawing any further attention this
reduces the velocity and intensity of
the attacks and protects the teams from
emotional labor exhaustion so
interaction limits one of the cool tools
that github offers us is a cool-down so
what we do is take advantage of github
x' temporary interaction limits we will
temporary limit who can comment create
pull requests and open issues among
existing users collaborators and prior
contributors after 24 hours the limit
expires and allows the users to go back
to participating in the discussion and
then we move on to temporary and
permanence a temporary block is time
limited as well the time frame is
decided on by our team at the time of
issuing depending on the severity of the
issue
the recommended defaults for us are 24
hours 48 hours and 7 days an indefinite
block is set for an unspecified amount
of time and may only be lifted for an
individual individual through a simple
majority vote of the moderation team
moderation of posts authored by non
collaborators may result in these non
collaborators being blocked temporarily
or indefinitely from further
participation in New York in the case
where a github account appears to have
been created with no intention to
collaborate in good faith we will
swiftly act without following the above
procedures including removing posts
blocking indefinitely and reporting
accounts to github but again that's
after receiving plus ones from teammates
accounts that are reasonably believed to
be BOTS are subject to immediate
blocking so we're pretty conservative on
handing out permanent or temporary
blocks for that matter temp box we now
log and set reminders to revisit these
bands these often tend to be viewed as
longer cooldown periods where we make
sure folks understand very clearly what
they did wrong I have not seen in my
history permanent bans revisited and
lifted I don't know of an instance where
we've regretted these scenarios because
we are very cautious to exercise that in
the first place and multiple plus ones
including the group they were
interacting with are considered so why
haven't I rehashed all of the gory
details of some of our flame wars are
ravenous trolls for one it's all still
there in issues and Twitter if you'd
like to waste your energy on reading
those old ghost stories but I don't
think it's good to spend energy this way
I prefer to spend energy on finding what
we've made mistakes on and need to fix
and then building we also have rules
around this end note so any collaborator
found to be violating the privacy of the
node moderation repo by repeatedly
sharing or discussing details of the
issues in any public forum or social
media risk being permanently removed
from the node github organization and to
speak clear to be removed from that
organization means you cannot contribute
to note the project so collaborators
maintainer x' leaders there's parents
showing up and doing work on a regular
cadence an open source because so many
of us volunteer rewards often come as
accolades and a pull request well merged
after building consensus through a great
release the ones who are trusted most
often have the most to lose but can also
be a win the lottery and disappear
factor for the ecosystem what if a
person in these legacy groups is seen as
a bad actor this goes far beyond the
moderation teams purview what if your
project doesn't have a way to address
this that doesn't mean you can't act but
it means you need to act with extreme
care and intention with
excellent and consistent communication
and that includes the folks who have
been reported on how many people do you
know are good at addressing elephants in
the room how about being able to look
someone in the eye that you work with
every day and tell them they need to
stop a behavior that other groups have
been people have been enabling for years
again most of us aren't taught these
skills so what we know in that scenario
is that it leads to a lot of people hurt
lost trust and decline productivity and
it takes a long time to recover and
instill lasting changes so we'll look
all of this but feeling like we had a
long way to go we called in the experts
in searching for a group that be able to
address our concerns for training we
know we need folks who were trained to
train and understand our globally
distributed set of individuals so it
turns out this isn't as common a domain
as you'd think
inspite of being this large world that
we operate in so we vetted and engaged
with online peer mediation platform team
known for building conflict management
programs and universities and workplace
settings they had the following
credentials so the plan is that the
moderation team and leadership including
the project of the board are the first
round of trainees so we're going through
six modules this is an hour and a half
per week and this is going to include
reviewing materials ahead of time as
well as evaluation discussion
role-playing and simulations including
github commenting and practicing with
feedback and that includes in curriculum
things like emotional intelligence
conflict style assessment for US culture
and conflict and online conflict
resolution skills which are very unique
skill set to have of course so then
we're going to be rolling that out to
the wider collaborator base raising the
level of fluency in calmly effectively
communicating through and Beyond
conflict with our collaborators in node
it's a very exciting prospect and we're
really grateful to have the resources
so we have great examples training and
are improving governance but there's a
final component missing self care if you
aren't a whole rested person how do you
build others up moderation and conflict
management take a lot of emotional
energy each of us who volunteer in this
work have to carve out time to replenish
in the ways that are meaningful to us so
in the community we talked about this on
the moderation team we take care so that
can include therapy meditation exercise
having other people who hold you
accountable to disengage from all of
this good work so in the tech world and
in JavaScript we like to think that
we're still in the Wild West and that
we're responsible for coming up with
solutions because the answer is don't
exist
but we don't need to reinvent the wheel
for our human relations problems there
are whole professions devoted to the
science of making these experiences
better great communication begins with
connection what makes us different from
one another is so much less important
than what makes us alike we all long for
acceptance and significance when we
recognize those needs and ourselves we
can better understand them in others and
that's when we can set aside our
judgments and just hear and yes I just
use Oprah sorry but that's it thank you
[Applause]